in the world history one of our class
members astutely came up before class
and said you talked about how Iran
became hyper-organized and ran out of
food when crisis hit and I didn't get in
my notes what the crisis was is that
Beth because they didn't say what the
crisis was and so now I have to tell you
what crisis was I had explained that the
great exuberance of Iran's culture its
urbanization it's you know phenomenal
difference from what Iran had always
been under the previous great Iranian
dynasties because it was centered in
Iran proper instead of being centered in
Iraq and I ascribed this to a to a
cotton boom it is you know perhaps
unnecessary to say that the cotton boom
affected only a fairly small portion of
the entire economy
I mean basically pre-modern countries
put most of their effort into producing
food they did not have the amount
surpluses of modern times they did and
their population was basically a rural
population so when you're looking at the
cotton boom you're not talking about
just endless fields of cotton but rather
at the at the margin but it was a margin
that was very important because if
stimulated manufacturing that stimulated
trade it became emblematic of the
of the ethos associated with the new
government it is interesting that the
this ceremonial garments that the
caliphs had manufactured in special
factories that consisted of plain cotton
or plumber in Egypt plain linen with
silk embroidery had a an analogue in the
area of ceramics so that the most famous
pottery style of Iran in the early
Islamic period consisted of plain white
al pottery with an ornamental writing in
an Arabic script and it was sort of a
ceramic version of what these ceremonial
garments were like because there really
was I believe an effort to to create a
new image and not simply have a new
government or a new ruling elite but but
I think the the notion of a new image
permeated Iran as Islam grew with the
the writing system of the Arabs perhaps
being more important than their language
in some respects because it was
emblematic of what was was new in Iran
but as I say there was a crisis the
crisis had a pre ambulant from about
9:20 to 9:40 a rather interesting moment
because at 9:45 the Caliphate in Baghdad
loses its authority to
two Iranian condottieri you know Iranian
bands that come in and take control of
Baghdad and yet maintain their ruling
centers in Iran so Baghdad becomes
secondary to the the new power center in
in the western part of Iran and these
the Iranian family known as the bully
it's also known as the boule hits
Hughley air he's a way it comes out in
Arabic they were from the mountains in
northern Iran they were quite
unsophisticated
but they were militarily strong the
Calif ADA become militarily weak so 945
you've got this this transition now as I
say this coincides with a moment in Iran
in the previous seating 20 years that is
marked by exceptionally cold weather
they say this is a pre annular moment
that is to say it got warm again after
the line after 9:40 9:45 and then it got
cold around 1007 and remained on average
surprisingly cold particularly for the
Iranians for about one hundred and
twenty five hundred thirty five years in
other words this is a significant
climate event I believe that I'm the
only person who has ever noticed this
climate event and now that I've written
about it I walk in the street I hear
people talking about hardly anything
else but
well so transformative has been my
insight but but there was no it was kind
of foolish of all my colleagues not to
have comment on this a generation or two
ago because we have chronicles
particularly about the city of Baghdad
which is written about extensively
because so many historians live there
and even if they lived in a later time
preserve the traditions of their and
what not you think of Baghdad we know a
lot about Baghdad has we've been bombing
it for a long time one of the things
that that you that you know if you look
at the history of Baghdad whether for
the last two or three centuries is that
it don't snow in Baghdad you know there
was a there were some snow flurries last
January they melted more or less as we
hit it became a newest story but in the
920's you would have a chronicle entry
that would say on such-and-such a date
in November 20 inches of snow fell on
Baghdad and stayed on the ground for
three weeks we don't have 20 inches of
snow falling on New York and staying on
the ground for three weeks in November
hmm 920 s the number of of extreme
winter events between 920 and 945 or so
is is really exceptional and then after
1007 you get another series it's not a
complete series but it's an intermittent
series of spectacularly cold weather now
of course they didn't have thermometers
thermometer had been invented but they
knew that there were
dimensions of cold and that some things
were you know more frizzy than others
and they would know that because they
would put down in the chronicle what
liquids froze so it's a wine froze or
rose water froze or animal urine froze
and so you can go back now we don't know
what the alcohol content was or what you
know etc Terry you can't be very precise
but you know that goes well below
freezing in order to get these things to
freeze we have descriptions of
date-palms freezing fig trees freezing
nomads who don't go out to winter
pastures because it's too cold you know
the edges of the Tigris River freezing
the canals at Baghdad freezing in Mosul
which is not all that far north of
Baghdad there is an instance cited in
one of these chronicles of a man who
took his class out and lectured on the
ice in the middle of the Tigris River so
this this is extraordinarily cold a
comparative look at chronicles from
three hundred years later
reveals virtually no freezing events and
before 9:20 there virtually no freezing
events this can of course simply be the
the vagaries of retention and sighting
of instances although there was one sort
of control for a later Chronicle it it
was possible to look at the frequency of
a memorable floods because of Titan
Freddie's flood memorably the the rate
at which you had catastrophic floods
remained a constant it was the cold is
what became the strong variable 20 years
ago I started collecting data on this or
rather I forced graduate students to
collect data on this I remember a
student doing a MA essay on climate in
Baghdad and then a seminar I was
co-teaching with a eminent political
scientist
he was asked by my co-teacher what was
the consequence of this cold weather and
he said I don't know I'm not sure it had
a consequence she well then why would
anyone write about it and I had to step
in and say because we're historians and
sometimes we just note things down
because they happen instead of because
they have a dependent variable or an
independent variable really fit into
some theory or something nevertheless in
time it became apparent that this did
have significance but it depended upon
finding more data now there were there
weren't going to be more data from the
Chronicles and so the data emerged five
or six years ago I can't run the
here in the publication of tree-ring
analyses from western mongolia this was
a project done by the lamont-doherty you
know Earth Observatory or wherever it's
called the branch of Columbia on the
other side of the Hudson River they
looked at tree rings from western
mongolia and found that there was indeed
a period of about a hundred and
thirty-five cold years there was a cold
period that shows up in western mongolia
now the significance of of that since
western mongolia is a long way from
baghdad comes from looking at the nature
of weather patterns in the Middle East
the Middle East is hot and dry in the
summer it has rains in the winter where
did the rain how do the rains come into
the area if this is the eastern end of
the Mediterranean Sea you have storm
tracks that go in the winter from the
Atlantic across the Mediterranean Sea
when they drop rain here in Lebanon and
Israel and Jordan and then if there's a
little bit left over they drop it here
on the Zagros Mountains between Iran and
Iraq and this is pretty much the
rainfall if you go south of here you
still have winds coming from the West
but they're dry winds because they're
coming off the Sahara this is desert
down here some Sahara so Arabia and
southern Israel lower Iraq southern Iran
they're very dry because the westerly
winds don't bring any moisture but the
ones that come off the Mediterranean do
bring moisture these
these storm tracks of the winter will
vary there are some periods when they're
farther to the north and then you get
bad matures in the North Sea in Holland
or Denmark or British Isles something
like that there is an approximately an
11 year oscillation known as the North
Atlantic Oscillation so that you have
the pressure gradients out here in the
Atlantic between the Azores and say
Iceland that pressure gradient will
change on this sort of regular quasi
regular basis and this is going to push
the storm tracks north or push them
south
so you have periodic droughts in the
Middle East that are actually fairly
predictable say a country like Syria
will go through a period of years when
they have plenty of rain for growing
grain and then a period of years when
they're like right now when they are
suffering severe drought and the
oscillation you know is used to predict
them you know the rains will return once
the oscillation resolves in the other
direction okay that that is if you read
general history books on the Middle East
or geography books they will say this is
your your your rainfall pattern now once
you get to the north
Oh farther out here and say here's the
Black Sea here's the Caspian Sea and
here's Central Asian and here's Mongolia
over here what you have out out here
every winter is
a big high-pressure area it's called the
Siberian high it's in Siberia or western
mongolia or eastern kazakhstan you know
where the exact center is is not
terribly important around this you know
of a broad circulation of air that that
brings cold weather across Central Asia
and Central Asia is indeed very frigid
that cold air is running into these
storm tracks from Mediterranean so in
other words these are low pressures low
pressure systems and are coming off the
Mediterranean but this is high pressure
and they don't really penetrate here so
you get so fall in high areas in Iran
and Turkey and it has to do with the
with the coming together of these of
these systems for some reason the
Siberian high seems to have become more
intense between say ten hundred and
eleven thirty five or so and that is a
relative measure by looking at the tree
wings it became colder and we don't know
why it became colder at least I don't
know why it became colder and as I say
nobody else has noticed it and so I
don't need anybody knows why I became
colder but it probably has something to
do with with broad hemispheric weather
changes because in exactly the same
period 950 - 1250 Europe becomes an
rewarm and this is called the Medieval
Warm Period for the mwp the Beattyville
Warm Period has been noticed for a long
time because this is when you had a much
more salubrious climate in northern
Europe is when the Vikings go to Nova
Scotia and go to Iceland and so forth
lots of studies have been done of how
nice it was to have Europe warm and it
lasted for about 250 300 years then it
was followed by something called the
Little Ice Age and Europe got cold again
until of the 19th century when it began
to warm up but the Medieval Warm Period
since it's been studied more than than
the Middle Eastern cold period people
have noticed that had certain
consequences it's a period during which
you have a phenomenal increase in
population in Europe so that the
population of Europe as a whole between
ten hundred and say thirteen forty of
the black death comes in 1348 and kills
everybody but let's say before the Black
Death ten hundred to thirteen forty the
general population of Egypt appears to
double and the population of North
Western Europe appears to triple it's a
period when agricultural production
expands vastly to both accommodate and
will actually produce this larger
population
it is likely that good weather produced
crop yields that generated a larger
population I mean it's fairly simple
equation that may or may not be easily
defendable but what it suggests is that
if the population is going up and eat in
in Europe and you have at exactly the
same time and I would suggest probably a
related cold period in the northern
Middle East then you probably going to
have a reduction in population in the
Middle East corresponding to a rise in
population in the Mediterranean not just
Europe actually but this would also be
Egypt and Syria so the Mediterranean
it's a Western phenomenon this appears
to have been the case I would suggest
that between ten hundred and twelve
hundred you probably had a fairly
substantial demographic shift in the
northern Middle East as people either
died or migrated so that what had been
the most exuberant urbanizing portion of
the Islamic caliphate is hit by crisis
when you read the chronicles
that touch on this they give you a lot
of details about weather for let us say
up until around 10:40 after that they
don't say much about the weather
although you get hints from time to time
presumably because people had become
accustomed to cold weather and they no
longer felt that it was so noteworthy
that they had to to write it down but
the the concomitant of cold weather that
is to say
poor crop yields you know leading to
famines and having epidemic diseases
associated with the famines this became
a common theme in The Chronicles as hey
after 1050 dealing with the northern
Middle East so it's a period in which if
you Winkle out what data weather weather
data specifically you can see the
evidence of the chilling but more
abundantly you see the indirect evidence
of the chilling in the form of social
disruption as groups compete for a
dwindling set of resources accompanied
by famines and epidemics and leading to
a to a fall in the population
this affects Iran from Isfahan northward
not southern Iran southern Iran is too
far south to really be hit by the by the
by the Siberian high it affects Iraq
from Baghdad north northwards but does
not affect the Arabian Peninsula it does
not seem to have the same effect in
Syria and Egypt although there appear to
be other disruptive climatic events
there and it seems to affect the eastern
part of what we now call Turkey
that is to say Eastern Anatolia which
was largely populated by Armenians it
was part of the Byzantine Empire and the
11th century is seeing 11 the 12th
century are seen by visiting historians
as a period of population decline in the
visiting Empire although not in the
Mediterranean portion of so
in other words the population on Cyprus
or Crete may appear to grow but the
population in the east declines and this
is a period when the when much of the
political center of Armenia shifts from
eastern Anatolia of the historical
Armenia to the Mediterranean coast at
the sort of juncture between Syria and
Turkey which was called little Armenia
or Silesia
Armenia and I think that's because of
migration that people left Armenia it
probably had a similar effect in Russia
but this is during the period the final
period of decline of the of Kiev and
Russia and while we have occasional
references to to famine and cold in
chronicles about Russia of that period
there we really don't know much in
detail about Russia at that time plus
Russia is always such a miserable place
that to have cold and famine and so
forth ISM isn't so memorable so but it
particularly hits Iran in Iraq now
cotton was oddly enough not that
powerfully affected because cotton
depends on a long hot summer and you
don't care very much about how cold it
gets the litter because this is a winter
phenomenon so you could continue to
produce cotton in Iran it's just that as
your food production is pressed there's
more and more need to bring to shift
production to food stuffs and away from
from cotton
this was present this pressure to
produce food appears to be present
before the already before 900 yes and
the economic percent of incentive
well well the economic incentive shows
up in the tax rates in 800 we happen to
have some some seemingly genuine data
from tax registers between the Year 800
and 900 in one local chronicle in Iran
in the year 800 the tax on let us say an
acre of cotton was double the tax on an
acre of wheat or barley the acre if
leader barley was mostly uh Neera gated
it was from natural you know winter
precipitation so you add the the tax
plus the cost of maintaining the
irrigation system these underground
cannot and you realize that the profit
margin for cotton must have been huge if
they could afford to to have attacked
the double rate and and pay the cost of
the irrigation there's one of the
indications of the boom character of the
cotton industry by the Year 900 the tax
on cotton is the same as it was in 800
but the tax on wheat and barley has
fallen by 80 to 90 percent in some
places it was barely being taxed and it
seems likely that the feeling that the
cities were getting hard to supply led
the government to
most attacks on wheat and barley on food
grains in order to try and maintain the
food supply of the country
this might seem precocious economically
that you would have a medieval
government that would see the
relationship between sustaining the
population and production in terms of
tax incentives or discouragements but we
also have an instance of this later on
in Iran in the in the 19th century when
but opium became such a phenomenally
profitable crop that the government
actually ordered its farmers to plant
wheat and barley because they were
running out of food so governments are
not just because they were medieval
doesn't mean that they were totally
obtuse so there appears to be an effort
to push the production into the into
food grains and at the same time
cotton loses its cachet the old brocade
and silk fabrics had been characteristic
of the pre-islamic
Sesana era returned in the 900s so that
the elite of the Muslim state who in 800
or 850 had worn voluminous cotton
garments with cotton head covers by the
year say 1050 they're wearing silk
brocade and the the embroidery that it
once showed up on cotton to show it was
a garment of special honor or
distinction has shifted to be an armband
on the midst of the brocade so what you
have is the return of silk everybody
always likes silk there's no and the ban
on silk had never applied
women they're just been on mint because
the public arena the women would it be
seen anyway maybe wearing some sort of
all-encompassing you know dress cover
but for the men the the notion of an
Islamic appearance ships and the ruling
elite shift back to this silk brocade
style the only people who don't follow
it are the mullahs and to this day
they're the ones who wear plain white or
plain black or plain brown and who who
stick to the signature Islamic visual
you know image that you had back
starting in the late 700 and established
in the 800 and 900 so Iran stops if we
know from geographers that it was a huge
producer of cotton and then the cotton
production largely stops and when it
finally restarts again say after in the
late 1200s when the weather warms up the
cotton growing is almost all in southern
Iran rather than northern Iran until
fairly modern times when they brought
cotton back to northern Iran and used it
as a area for exporting cotton to Russia
and then that came to an end when the
Russians conquered the Central Asian
khanates and started growing their own
cotton and turned countries like was
Beck Astana and Turkmenistan into mono
mono cultural cotton producing areas
anyway that's online my point is that
that this this concatenation of climate
agriculture and demography shifts the
history of the Islamic world what had
been the center of the Muslim world Iraq
and Iran flow from led to say the
Abbasid revolution 750
you know by eleven hundreds Iraq and
Iran are no longer the uncontested
center in the Muslim world Iran in
particular in the 1100s suffers loss of
population Baghdad the great capital
becomes sort of a gutted out half
deserted City by by the late 1100s and
eventually in the in the early twelve
hundreds the Mongols attack now all of
the decline of Iraq and Iran that is
acknowledged by both Muslim and modern
Western historians is ascribed to the
Mongols they came in and they destroyed
everything that is almost certainly
untrue it appears that the Mongols
invaded a devastated land they
devastated and deep populated land that
had become devastated for reasons that
were not fully understood at the time
having to do with the factors I've
talked about and so the the the
onslaught of the Mongols appear is all
the more catastrophic because of factors
that predated the the coming of the
Mongols in the same way that's been
argued that the onslaught of the Black
Death in Europe was was exacerbated by
factors of falling agricultural
production in comparison with
consumption needs in the decades
immediately preceding of the Black Death
uh-uh this is something that is an
awkwardness for for many people in other
words when you deal with climate change
causing things or being constructed as
causing things many many readers of
history and writers of history become
very edgy because they think that people
make history they don't like to think
about impersonal forces making history
so that like as we'll see in later on
and in a later lecture they love to talk
about the Spaniards coming to the new
world and creating a new European
experience they don't really like to
talk about the epidemics that bumped off
most of the indigenous population
because what's there to say everybody
got measles and smallpox and hell died
and the Spaniards took over huge areas
that we're about to be emptied of people
and you know how could you celebrate
Columbus Day now some people would say
well the the Europeans deliberately
caused these diseases I don't think for
the most part they did maybe Jeffrey
Amherst did but most people didn't it
just happened so ascribing huge impact
to the Mongols makes it sort of like
describing the huge impact to Columbus
on the Spaniards in the new world but it
was other factors that that made it such
a huge historical crisis
well the consequences of this are things
I want to go into a bit one of them I've
mentioned briefly last time and that is
that from let us say 1150 onward most of
the cultural production of the meat of
the the Middle Eastern Muslim world
comes from Syria and to a lesser degree
from Egypt Iran and Iraq drop out of the
equations although you often find that
the scholars and thinkers who are
working in Syria in Egypt are Iranians
who have even see by their family names
that they have migrated from from
elsewhere also the Iranians migrate into
what is now turkey so that even though
what is now Turkey Anatolia is a joins
Syria and Iraq which are Arabic speaking
areas the second language becomes
Persian after you know after Turkish
rather than Arabic so you have a big
shift toward the Mediterranean after the
two to three centuries of great emphasis
on Iran and Iraq that's one impact
another impact has to do with the coming
of the Turks from the 10 30s onward down
to the present day or let us say down to
oh I don't know 1925 or so that's a good
nine hundred years the dominant
political forces in the Middle East have
been people who
have had Turkish as a mother tongue it's
one of the great moves in world history
the coming of Turkish speakers into
positions of great political authority
Turks had been known in the Middle East
in Islamic political context since the
830's I would say for 200 years Turks
have been known because they were
purchased as slaves as boys in Central
Asia and brought to Baghdad or elsewhere
and trained to be professional military
soldiers and they were known by the term
mam Luke literally meaning something
that is owned and is often translated as
a white slave or a military slave or the
more generic term golem which is it's a
Turkish youth often translated as a page
as in a pageboy
because of a curious phenomenon of
Islamic studies which prefers to use
archaic English whenever possible
because it exotic eise's whatever is
going on but so these these Turkish
youth would be you know slaves and they
might be soldiers or they might be
courtiers or something of that sort
so we know the Turks were there before
8:30 the earliest mention of Turks under
that word comes from Chinese sources
where they're called to cue and those go
back to the 6th century so that let us
say in the 500s one or two centuries
before before Islam for any Arab armies
that out there we know that there were
Turks living up here somewhere in
Central Asia they originated west of
Mongolia in the Altai mountains
supposedly that's the earliest homeland
and we have some archaeological
materials that seem to perhaps fit into
that early model and they have moved
across Central Asia inter Asia in the
way that nomads often do if back and
forth not in a particular focused
direction but they're making use of the
of the grasslands and they are nomadic
herders so from 500 let us say so
they'll say from 550 until ten hundred
something like that they are there in
Central Asia north of where the Muslim
state is located and we have details
about interactions between Muslim rulers
and and Turkish groups and we know of
individual Turks who are brought in as
slaves if I said and trained as soldiers
what happens in the ten twenties and
thirties is that they come in as tribes
or as large population elements acting
on their own volition
rather than
purchased and put in training barracks
the coming of the Turks in other words
is a specific event that we can date we
have one Chronicle that talks about when
the first Turks moved into Iran and it
happens in two episodes both in the
first third of the of the 11th century
the question is why did they move how
can you be satisfied roaming around
Central Asia for centuries
then suddenly decide to go to Iran it's
that as though Iran is that attractive
it's not full of grass lamps it's not
great horse country Iran is really dry
and the area they move into is sort of
semi desert so why did they move south
if you read books on the earliest in
Turks those authors who address the
question will explain it it will say
political and possibly population
pressure and feuding led the Turks to
move south actually there's no evidence
to either support or refute that tribes
in Central Asia presumably are always in
some sort of complicated political
situation demographic pressure who knows
you know sometimes yo more people some
to have even less it's it's simply an
effort to explain something that seemed
to be inexplicable alright my
explanation is that they move south
because the weather got bad when I first
thought of that I thought what a cool
explanation it gets cold and the Turks
move south into into Iran which is also
cold and I thought why would they do
that they have horses horses are native
to Central Asia
they've been freezing their tails off
for you know thousands of years tens of
thousands years they have sheep sheep
grow wool you know they're they're not
going to be just comforted to hump
camels they're native to the area why in
the world would the church so move south
simply became because it got cold and
the answer appears to be that in
particular groups of Turks who came into
Iran known as the Ovilus are different
spellings of this various ones of this
these Turks appear to have had a come a
come combination in their economy
between pastoral nomadism living from
the products of their animals in a more
or less autarkic or subsistence fashion
and a cash economy where they produce
something that they could sell or rent
for for some sort of material value what
can you produce in Central Asia that
would be of that value and how is it
specifically affect the olhos Turks the
answer to that is hybrid camels now
all right here is your your normative
one-hump camel and of course he has a
cousin the - up camel has a lot of hair
because the two hump camel is adapted to
cold weather what a camel is not what's
extraordinary about the one milk camel
in biological terms is it's absolutely
remarkable set of adaptations to torrid
temperatures including the number of
humps because
the hump is simply a depository of fat
and when you are without food and these
both species of camels can go without
food literally for months
they're simply consuming the fat that is
stored up in there and their hump or
their humps but the difference between
storing fat in two humps and storing fat
in one hump is a ratio between the
volume of the hump and the surface area
of the comb if you have one large cone
you can have a lot of stuff in it and
the surface area is much less than the
surface area if you have the same amount
of stuff in two cones and all of you
who've forgotten your solid geometry
from from sophomore year in high school
or something you'll have to brush up on
this but it's true
I know it because an Arab has now
written about it in detail stealing my
stuff without any acknowledgement
because I think I'd the first person
who's ever actually written an
explanation of why you have one up
instead of two the reason for this is
that one um camels survive and torrid
weathers in toward weather by having a
temperature gradient of about 11 degrees
Fahrenheit in the morning they're at 90
degree LS a so 92 degrees Fahrenheit the
day goes long they get hotter and hotter
and harder they just absorb solar
radiation and when their temperature
gets to those from 92 to 103 after 11
degrees Fahrenheit they start to
perspire but during that entire period
of temperature increase they're
perfectly healthy appetites fine their
activities fine you know whereas humans
go up 2 or 3 degrees and they're sick
the camel can go up 11 degrees with one
help camels and remain healthy as soon
as they hit that upper level then they
start to perspire but by that time the
sun's going down getting a little breeze
off the Mesa and it's getting cool again
so they don't lose a lot of heat by
perspiration a lot of water by
perspiration which is the normal way
mammals will cool themselves during the
cool desert night their temperature goes
back to its basal level and they heat up
again so that stay now in order to
maximize this camels minimize the
exponent one of camels minimize their
exposure to solar radiation there are
large animals but during the hottest
part of the day they will sit with their
legs folded under them so their legs are
not exposed to the Sun when they are
sitting they will all face the same
direction they will either face the Sun
or face away from the Sun so that the
the the the profile that is exposed to
solar radiation is minimal they will not
sit sideways of the Sun to expose their
their side
and they will only have their a single
hump exposed and as the hump diminishes
because of consumption of the fat the
the skin is elastic and pulls it down
flat now to up camels where they consume
all of the fat in their humps develop a
condition that I call a floppy hump
they're like two empty bags usually one
flops to the left one flops to the right
and it's just about is unattractive a
feature of you know camel pulchritude as
you can imagine you can have this really
cool sleek profile brought up camel or
you can have old floppy hump in the next
stall because the two on cameras were
not adapted to cold weather they're not
adapted to hot weather but it also means
that the London camels cannot survive
very far to the north so that of the
best or at least the most extensive
writer on camels or rather on animals as
a whole in medieval Islam an Arab named
Joseph actually of African origin says
the reason the Arabs did not in it would
did not move into Anatolia into
Byzantine Anatolia at the time of the
conquest it's because their camels
couldn't survive it was too cold for the
Syrian camels so they would invade they
would have a conquest they would raid
someplace but they never went in to stay
instead they moved out to the east where
their camels could survive and the hot
summers and make it through the cold
winters in Iran they had two large
caravans of two large garrison centers
one in northern Afghanistan what is now
the city of mazar-e-sharif and the other
in
turkmenistan what is now the city of
mayor and these had tens of thousands of
Arab soldiers who had come who were sent
by the governor's and Caleb's in Iraq
and Syria Arabia to the east and they
brought with them tens of thousands of
camels this is how the one-hump camel
appeared in large numbers east of Iraq
it was not an unknown Amal animal we
have some images of 1-up camels that are
pre-islamic out in Central Asia but they
appear to be ceremonial animals they
appear to be rarities now you had lots
and lots of one help camels in these two
specific areas both of these areas
appear to have developed an industry of
crossbreeding one and two hump camels in
northern Afghanistan the crossbreeding
was done by Arabs who became known as
the richest areas of the East because of
the profit from the trade and in
Turkmenistan the breeding was done by
Turks particularly in northern
Turkmenistan up between that northern
part of the Caspian Sea and the Aral Sea
Turkmenistan is essentially it's here's
this is Iran this is the southern border
at last on there's a Caspian Sea is the
western border for it medicine the Oxus
river that flows down from mouths Organa
stands for the eastern border you have
the RLC up here and but most of the
interior of Turkmenistan is a desert
it's known as the car a club desert
means black sand and Turkish
the reason the church never moved south
before was because they were in
grasslands in Central Asia and they
would have to cross this this big desert
they could send a raiding party across
the desert but to move the wife and the
kids and the sheep and the horses and
the camels south across the desert big
big project of course the way they did
it when they finally did it was that
they went up the Oxus River until they
got to Iran then they went across here
and essentially they relocated from the
northern edge of the Karakum desert to
the southern Angela kharkom desert which
has a temperature differential from
north to south of about 12 degrees so
they moved to to warmer weather we know
exactly where they settled because it's
stated in The Chronicles also stated
twice in The Chronicles that they
settled as camel herders not as horse
herders they brought horses with them
but there they were known for for their
camels now what is it - what is the
hybrid the cross you've got an animal
that looks like this it has a long mound
on the back and how that may or may not
have an indentation you know 4 5 inches
deep toward the front the indication is
that the the the front hump is being
suppressed genetically in the cross it
it is an animal that has what is known
as hybrid vigor and to say it is larger
and stronger than either of its parents
it also is an animal that does not
produce naturally reproducing herds
unlike a mule across between a horse and
a donkey it is fertile it can have young
but if it breeds with
either parent not literally a parent but
if it breeds with either a one-hopper
film camel the next generation reads
back to the original if it if they if
they breed with one another the product
is a is a runt that has no economic
value and has a very low survival value
so this is an animal that only exists
like the mule if there's a market it
makes absolutely no sense to have hybrid
camels if you do not have someplace to
sell them or if you're not by using them
yourself some fashion typically what you
had would be a large herd of female one
hump camels and the small number of two
humps stud males this industry has
virtually disappeared I do have some
photographs of small herds that have
been spotted in recent decades but
basically it's gone and is largely
unknown now the value of this for that
particular area was that you had one one
commercial use that stood out and that
was the Silk Road the Silk Road uses
camels for transportation
when the film Silk Road first begins
let's say circa 300 BC we find there are
figurines of Silk Road camels found in
the vicinity of Baghdad I say in Iraq
that have every indication that they are
to help camels they are to help camels
and originally the camels in the Silk
Road were too humped animals that would
be brought to Iraq but by the in the
Islamic period the practice seems to
have become that from Samarkand and
Bukhara East and I would say from this
area in Uzbekistan from there East he
was to up camels and from here West you
used one up camels but in fact you are
using hybrid camels so you have a
transshipment point where all the goods
that are coming from China are taken off
and unloaded from the - um camels and
loaded back on the one on to the one up
camels for the hybrids and I think
hybrids are the obvious choice here
because they are stronger than the two
up camel they're stronger than one hump
camel they are Hardy enough to to do OK
in winter but they also can deal with
the summer temperatures they're sort of
in the middle range in terms of weather
adaptability today in Iran all the
camels virtually have one hub in
Turkmenistan this area here all of the
camels have one home once you get over
here to Kyrgyzstan Kazakhstan all the
camels have two humps
in the pre-islamic period we know that
the camels of Turkmenistan had two humps
not one huh because they show up on
coins and they show up in the regalia of
kings in that area so we know there's a
big change in livestock we know the only
people who had those livestock were the
Arabs and we have this these indications
of a breeding industry the breeding
industry was conducted by Turks they
produced animals for the Silk Road and
when the cold weather came the female
animals were dying and had to be moved
south because this is by far the most
northerly extension of the population of
one health camels and this is a reason
they moved now it there are certain
implications of this if this theory is
is true it's certainly the best theory
around because all the other theories
may you know have no evidence whatsoever
and I have Oh a good three or four
sentences of evidence but if this is
true then there are a couple of
implications one of them is that the
Turks who came into the Middle East in
the 1000s and form a state known as the
Seljuks which metastasizes westward and
takes over pretty much the whole Middle
East either directly or indirectly these
Turks the Seljuk family had many
personal names that came from the Bible
so we've you know when they first
appeared we have people who have names
like Dawood for David mchao for Michael
Issa for Jesus
it was very clear that Suleiman for
Solomon very clear that they had had
some association with biblical naming
tradition before they enter Iran there
have been two theories one is that there
have some connection with the Turks who
lived at the mouth of the Volga River in
north of the Caspian Sea who were are
said to be Jews a little hard to see how
Jesus gets in there and that therefore
their their affinities are in this
direction the other possibility is that
they had affinities in this direction
where the Turks who were merchants on
the Silk Road were very often we Gers of
the people who currently live in the
North West Province of China and John
province and the Leaguers are known to
have been Nestorian Christians for the
most part so it appears that the seljuqs
were tied into the Silk Road
commercially and tied into the culture
of the Christian historians to some
degree although they became Muslims now
it's turn cold
the tribes have decided that they want
to save their livestock they asked
permission of the Sultan to move into
Iran and live on the on the fringe of
the desert in what today as the southern
edge of Turkmenistan the Sultan gives us
permission and they move in they prove
to be a disruptive element so a couple
of decades later another group asks
similarly for permission to move in the
Sultan says no because your predecessors
were disruptive they say well we'll take
care of that we'll police our own ranks
we'll get rid of those nasty overs who
preceded us and the Sultan says no I
will fight you and they have a fight
and the Sultan loses and then the gates
are opened for the Turks so that in the
ten thirties you no longer have a state
that is opposed to the migration of
Turks into the Middle East and this is
when the seljuq dynasty originates they
are the first Turkic dynasty in Iran and
by 1050 they are in Baghdad and taking
over from the beds as controllers of the
Caliphate what they are not aware of
because nobody is really aware but was
that the economy of Iran and Iraq was
dying and that economy was based on
agriculture with a special place for
cotton particularly for Iran and the
climate change was making it bad for
agriculture but the the Seljuks didn't
really I'm not gonna say they didn't
care but it wasn't their focus of
attention their focus of attention was
the Silk Road that was what they knew
about that was what they were tied into
and when the silk brocade returned in
force under the seljuqs and even a
little bit before them they're
reflecting the trade along the Silk Road
plus the growing practice of cotton of a
silk production along the lowlands of
the Caspian Sea and Iran
so there they're really oriented toward
the Silk Road you can see in the seljuq
period
absolutely undeniable indications of
Chinese art traditions entering entering
Middle East Chinese pottery designs it's
just a sea change in the culture of Iran
and eastern Middle East under the
seljuqs as you get this sort of rebirth
of interest in the Silk Road one of the
evidences for this comes in the area of
kleynach prior to the Seljuks as I
mentioned before the coinage of the
eastern part of the Muslim domains of
the Middle East was silver the silver
dirham the silver dirham remains the
dominant coinage throughout the pre
seljuq period in in Iran and Iraq even
when they ran out of silver so you had
something called the silver famine when
people would add other metals to the
silver in order to make it go farther so
you've got silver with high quantities
of lead or copper or sometimes copper
coins would simply say on them this is a
dirham because it was the standard
currency the size and shape change a
little bit or the size that the diameter
and thickness but basically this is a
silver zone under the Seljuks
the silver disappears completely and it
becomes a great Center for gold so that
under the Seljuks the primary claim egde
is the gold dinar which up to that point
had never played nearly so great a role
in the eastern part of the the Caliphate
now the difference between these is that
silver coins are great for facilitating
low and moderate level trade and
manufacturer
you need small currency gold is very
difficult to use because it's so
valuable but on the other hand if your
primary interest is in Silk Road trade
where you're dealing with high value
goods coming by Caravan or in payment or
in paying your army gold is great for
paying the army because you don't need
all that many coins in order to to get
the pay but once your silver currency
disappears you no longer have the
wherewithal to support a lively trading
and an manufacturing economy so
manufacturing continues but it moves
toward the luxury end the consumers
become the courts rather than the
bourgeoisie and one of the indications
of this is that for the first time in
Islamic history artists start to sign
their work so we start to get
magnificent painted tiles where we know
the name of the artist
same thing with pottery same thing with
miniature painting because now the the
consumption pattern is moving toward the
the court of the soul Tom and it's a
luxury consumption pattern and the the
middle class that had benefited so
enormous Lee from the from the cotton
boom is now suffering and disappears and
the astonishing thing is that what this
produces is the Tea Party angry Iranian
saying I'm really fed up I'm not going
to take it anymore you know because the
rich are getting richer and I'm getting
screwed if it didn't happen exactly that
way but what did happen is that people
left why they migrated later Islamic
history
is dominated by Egypt in Syria to such
an extent that most people never think
of what Iran once was in one time that
next to Baghdad unquestionably the
biggest and most important city of the
Islamic world was Nisha poor in Iran not
Cairo not Damascus but this shifts the
whole notion of the balance between
arabs and persians Arabic speakers and
Persian speakers
oddly enough the Persian speakers
flourish in Anatolia where they migrate
under the auspices of the Seljuk Turkish
rulers and Turkish poetry becomes well
known throughout Turkish air Persian
poetry comes well known in Turkish areas
and well known in India but the Arabs
don't know anything about it so it's a
period of cultural shift now when we
design this chapter of the book first of
all I didn't know I was what I was going
to do to learn this this stuff but even
more we were influenced by one of the
great changes associated with the study
of world history and this is the
redemption of the Mongols for what eight
hundred years the Mongols were the most
destructive people known and you know
the notion of of writing Israeli Mongols
was a history of rape ein and pillage
and you know pyramids of skulls mass
murder world historians love to say that
the rule of the Mongols is parallel to
the voyages of discovery of the
Europeans that is say the two great
events the maritime adventure of the
Europeans and the terrestrial adventure
of the Mongols they are the great
threshold between a long time ago and
not so long ago and so the Mongols
become rejuvenated writing books and
praise of the Mongol Empire as a in
flourishing business and nothing this is
wrong I think in many ways that it's
that's a correct apprehension but it's a
huge huge change to to redeem the
Mongols but when we were looking this
chapter what it meant was because about
one of our writers really do a lot about
the Mongols we decided we should stop
the chapter in 1258 because that's when
the Mongols destroyed Baghdad from the
point of the history of Islam 1258 is
right in the middle of crucial things
and it creates the notion that the
Mongols are a watershed whereas in fact
the watershed had come a century too
earlier with the climate change which
the Mongols ended up being the
beneficiaries of but what they did in in
the Middle East for the most part wasn't
as important as other things that were
happening within Islam that fell outside
the chronological limits of the chapter
but that means that I can talk about
those things in a later lecture that
deals with the Mongols in the West and
this is all we have for today
you